on veut pincer les impôts une promesse
électorale qui a été une main de foire
répétée elle était même sur les
pancartes kakistes de la dernière
élection partielle à Montréal cet hiver
le gouvernement s'apprête à réduire d'un
point d'eux pourcentage le taux de ces
deux premiers paliers d'imposition mais
c'est tout à fait magnifique quelle
bonne nouvelle enfin ça fait toujours du
bien à notre pouvoir d'achat notre
budget l'inflation a fait beaucoup de
mal dernièrement donc je pense que c'est
une bonne chose la population est
peut-être contente mais la mesure est
loin de faire l'unanimité parmi les
experts on s'est demandé si c'était une
bonne idée une bonne politique publique
on est venu à la conclusion que non dans
une étude qu'elle vient de publier
l'iris jugent d'abord la promesse
inéquitable là où ces bases d'impôts là
vont être les plus
vont être les plus bénéfiques vont
rapporter le plus c'est les revenus de
90 000 à 100.000 dollars pour l'année
fiscale 2023
un gang 100 000 dollars par année plus
devrait économiser 814 dollars d'impôts
ceux qui déclarent un salaire de 50000
sauveront 328 dollars et les salariés
qui touchent 30 000 dollars n'auront
droit qu'à 128 dollars de réduction
l'iris souligne aussi que la promesse
Coutras un milliard 800 millions de
dollars au gouvernement chaque année de
l'argent qui aurait pu être investi pour
améliorer les services publics au Québec
la tendance est au baisse d'impôts
depuis 20 ans
si on inclut le dernier et dernière
année du mandat libéral c'est 4 points 1
milliard de dollars qui est
de revenus de rentrer fiscale de moins
qu'on observe au gouvernement qu'on voit
très bien qu'il y a une crise dans les
services publics on voit que on a besoin
d'un réel investissement Québec rate sa
cible disent les syndicats comme il y a
pénurie dans les services publics ces
économies d'impôts seront vite engloutis
par le recours grandissant des citoyens
secteur privé non on a besoin d'avoir
des services on a besoin d'avoir
quelqu'un qui va être là dans nos écoles
dans nos hôpitaux que ça craque pas
qu'il y ait pas de crise puis là pour
l'instant c'est pas ça donc faut faire
des choix le milieu des affaires quant à
lui est divisé le Conseil du patronat
s'oppose obèse alors que la Chambre de
commerce de Montréal est la Fédération
canadienne de l'entreprise indépendante
sans réjouissent certainement aider les
gens en période d'inflation puis
apprendre des décisions selon leur
réalité ça va être un bon coup de pouce
quand on regarde ça on est une des
places les plus taxées pour les citoyens
dans l'OCDE François Vincent ajoute que
ces recettes fiscales que Québec va
perdre n'aurait pas nécessairement été
investi dans nos services publics on
regarde dans les 10 dernières années
est-ce que nos services publics se sont
améliorés donc peut-être que ce qui est
temps d'avoir une réflexion sur
l'amélioration des services sans
nécessairement aller vers une
augmentation du fardeau fiscal des
citoyens on connaîtra les mesures
détaillées du budget québécois
à 16 heures mardi ici jean-Sébastien
Cloutier Radio-Canada Montréal